I've got to see high vlog length. I'm so sorry about being late. Oh, I'm 11 minutes late
Okay, no wonder everyone's peaking. I'd be peaking too shit. I'd be gone too
Not gonna lie chief. I'd be I'd be gone
Okay, I
Missed run. It's almost like she's here. She's she is here. She's just
We'll kid record an ASMR and whenever I go to record ASMR like and the sound effects
You don't just record like one minute of the sound effect like to have an hour. Sorry. I'm in the middle of a conversation
So when you record ASMR and especially when you record the fully sounds that you need
You don't just record one minute and then loop it and then that's it
No, you have to record like a decent amount of the sound or else
It's very obvious. You just look at the same thing over and over again, and it becomes un-relaxing
It defeats the purpose of the ASMR. Okay?
Good morning. Good evening again afternoon. I apologize for being so severely late, but I promise I have a fan
Tastic reason as to why I have
Finally recorded the missing SFX that is needed for my collab with Poseidon
My update is the Yumi
Extrawny collab kiss kiss and is being edited as we speak. Hopefully. I don't know maybe I
Have also sent off here. You dropped this bread, but for the great. Thank you for the three extended membership
I also
sent off a
My 7k special ASMR is actually handcam
It's is very similar to the stream that occurred yesterday and reverberation
It was so similar that we were begging for
and
The reason why the hip-kno
Turning into my pup has been changed is I do not have a fucking writer's bone in my body right now
I
Don't know if you have seen the tweet. You may or may not have seen the tweet from the official velour
Twitter
And management is looking to hire multiple script writers
and
so guess whose job it is to fucking make sure you write the way I like it and
It feels extra scumbaggy because
Basically, we have to give you a prompt and you have to rate it within I'll give so base
This game is silly have you played it before it just came out it came out last month, and
Yes, literally 12 hours after you ended the stream. Mmm. Okay, so nice
And pre-recorded chat. No
11th of September 2024
Strongly had a lot of fun and there was some wait is Brian talking. I can't hear him
Could you hear Brian there? I couldn't hear him
This stream was pre-recorded in the 11th of September 22 for strong. He had a lot of fun and there was some derpy moments
And
Similar so you're gonna get puppy mode again. No, I am taking a break from pop mode after the old
We can hear Brian, how the fuck can you hear Brian and I can't well, can you hear this?
Did you hear her?
Could you hear her? I don't know reflin. Are you a
Who gentlemen
And of course you can't hear because it's pre-recorded. Okay that one that's smart to shut fuck up
Okay, so I sent away a collab audio to be edited
Okay, but that wasn't all I sent away the hand cam pre-recorded video for a 7k celebration to be edited I
Then sent away 10 shorts the previous day to be edited. I
Also have a bonus short about ASMR that is being caught up now to be sent away to be edited
And then after today, I'm in the Poseidon collab sound effects
And then tomorrow I'm gonna send away the collab with me script
Oh
Did I miss the puppy hypno stream no
You didn't miss it and getting replaced and I'm gonna do it another bit, okay
So in the future, there's gonna be a hypnotizing you to be my puppy
video a stream, okay
But thank you for waiting on me you're such a oh, you're such a
I love
As proof this is pre-recorded story with an eye that's pre-recorded real. Oh
Brother this guy
Okay, so peggel in what is bagel in for a peggel in other than refling
Ah
You are
Beggel in for a peggel in and yes
This is replacing the hit no puppy screen stream because I have no writing bones in my body
and I
Have no
Motherfucking writing things in my body because I'm gonna have to deal with those who are applying
But don't worry. It's all done through management. I will not directly talk to you
You have to get dealt with management
So this game is called peggel in it is pachinko based
Kind of RNG. It's almost similar to the dungeon clawler with guys guys
For more info on why we don't have the hypno see I highly recommend mummy's membership. You'll get interested in
Wait
No, wait, is there I don't know you had a different bone in you yesterday
Ah
Right, okay peggel in peggel in is a jackoff
Jack of all trades holy shit, right my brain hasn't woken up yet
Peggel in is a jack of all trades with with access to almost all orbs and relics
flexibility and adaptability
Adaptability are the keys and brown freight left at your new short with a ping
Sin I genuinely thought that was my pain because I'm so used to it being like 300 fucking
400 I was like, yeah, this is an hour's character
Higher chatter number two. I can't wait for left for dead streams night. We should be tonight. Wait. No, I already happened
You're teasing it's not pre-recorded
Starting by like peg Lynn tuition battle rewards and chest contain additional options. Yeah, give me that whatever that is
Yeah, when a battle at least a hundred ten, right? Okay. No, give me the other thing. Yeah. Yeah, play that wherever that is
Start each battle with one plus must
must circle
Mercical must the call he'll six win reloading right. I've never played this by the way
Sin ASMR club win. What was sin?
Sin wait, sin. Can I say something inappropriate? Hold on. Let me DM you
Where are you? Where are you saying?
Sin can I see that on stream right of DM to her we'll find out if I'm allowed to see it on stream
Yeah, we're gonna find out live if I'm allowed to see it
It should probably be like shut the fuck up bitch. I'll be okay
Right, what's pink house of slime walls and bottom bones. No peace off ghost. I'm not doing slain
Sure
Slap on I've never played this I watched someone play it and it said it was Pachinko
And I was like this reminds me of dungeon claw alert where it's kind of just RNG be oh my god
You're so cute little refling a little El goblino
Permission to leak. Wait, did you see?
The third leak has hit the pentagon
She's not replied yet. Oh my god, I'm in trouble
It's literally called Pachinko before anyone's like are you saying a slayer? No, I'm not saying a slayer
Right, so this is you up here top left or this is us
We're together in this this is us morph together because you're green and I'm green and then these are the enemy
Are you squiddin me right now? I don't know. Are you squiddin me right now?
You me guess what you me
Our edit got sent away. So the ASMR is coming. You need to send me a PNG of yourself. No
Send me a PNG of yourself. No or multiple PNG if I didn't ask for one yet because the video is getting made soon
Um, what the fuck upcoming purple slimes
pebble
Three three damage for a neutral four for a exclamation mark. No special effects. Okay
We're just analyzing. I watched someone play this for five seconds passed out and I was like, yeah, this game will do it
Right, okay. Let's just so there's 60 health
First the peeing of this she's got my colleague on please
I
Sins laughing. So, you know how someone said uh, oh that was rather satisfying
Oh, that was the dagger does very little damage as a regular attack
But it's incredibly strong and a critical hit if you don't think you can hit this turn
You can disband the dagger by using the garbage icon. Oh, that's a bit sweet
um
Sin said I'm allowed to say uh, I'm doing a collab with she being a zero tonight. So
We'll get that sent your way
Um
It looks like a rogue like pachinko. It is
It's so cute
Right. Okay. So instead I can leak it. You know how someone said when are you collabing with sin on the ASMR?
Uh roleplay
Uh
Not in this life
In the next life
I
But what does that mean? What could that possibly mean?
What could it mean? No one knows
I'm just doing this at random by the way. I don't know. I'm just enjoying it is a cute little game
Yellow sire tona boost when things go your way
I'm gonna
Fucking send it some c4 when you can hit with a bomb shout out with your money gang. You're graduating now
What?
No, please tell me it's really obvious. What I've just said
Camey ball hazard applies poison. Oh, I do like a good poison
Oh, I love poison though
Oh, I love poison electromagnet strong attraction to our ball. You would like me to our ball yet the next
Damn schedule. It's obvious. I'm trolling right. We'll stop trolling right now
Ha ha ha
You mean your past life on me, not now. No, I don't see it sir
Uh applies spin fiction on crit apply
Cauldron bubble applies spin fake. No, I like poison. I'm here for the poison. Sure
I'ma buy whatever that was upgrade an orb
an orb
Massive damage. No, let's go all out on poison poison poison. I love me some poison. Oh, I could have healed
Oh, I thought I'm not taking any damage
Is this easy mode
There's a chess or there's a question mark
I can't hear Brian
No, I'm not fucking playing slam rancher again
Right, we got a chest. What's what's inside the box?
You should stop trolling now
How many lives do you have? I have no idea. This is genuine first time playing. I think it's fucking cute and adorable
I'm gonna work with the game studio. Sorry. I said it. I want to work with this game studio
They're so cute the artworks like exactly what I want like if I were to produce video games is a
That tell me what I want. So this is the cutest fucking thing I've ever played in my life. Okay
The pre-recorded donations are cooking away shut up hired refling
Thank you for the tip, but it's just your bush. Right. I'm gonna hydrate with tea
Wait, what happened to slime rancher? Right
So, do you know the the the story of feature versus yapping through the tutorial then refusing to open up and look at anything
That would mildly help them and also perfectly dodging any serious advice and chat
You know that tale is all this time
I did that during slime rancher and gave up in an hour and 30 minutes into the game. Okay
Every reload grants balance. I don't know what that means projectile attacks will pierce their enemies with
Transparency excelling other original damage. Sure. Let's mop the floor with these enemies
Fuck yeah, holy shit. No, don't put me down there coach. I don't want to die. Jeez
What
Wait, am I dumb a little bit, but that's okay
Slime rancher is annoying. I think
Uh, I completely hunt. No, no the game's good. I'm sure the game is good
I just handicapped myself because I'm a dumb ass. I was yapping through the entire thing honestly, so don't mind me
Don't mind me
Is this girl just a battle? I think so
I'm excited for the part of this stream where strony gets stuck on that one boss for like 20 minutes and rages
I can fucking read that. I might not be able to hear that. I can read that you little shit
You little fucking shit
I love the terrible one
Thank you. I love food. Oh for the tip you stinker stinker tin
Hmm, I love this game so much. Wait, everyone's played this game, but me
It just looked like a cute little game. Is this a vtuber game? Ah, and no being funny. This is the first time
I've freaking seen the game
I'm a dumb ass
Have been like, oh this game just looks so
It's like a game
She said the thing never heard but I don't play this game anymore
This game has been available for early access for a while. Oh my god. My voice is cracking
Ah
Bouncy deals no damage heals you for each pegle hit permanently remove
From your deck after it's used right? Well, then what's that effing point of having it?
Let's do more attack strong attraction to be weak attraction to be a create effect is full strength for suit now
Yeah, we'll do that one sure add it and then upgrade an orb. I don't have enough money, but that's okay
Look at us go. We're so cute. Oh, we're still fighting
Wait, so if I keep trying to go in the question mark, is it can I just like go down here?
It's a niche popular game. Uh, I've played it because it's a roguelike
Can't believe we're all binding of Isaac players out here
Who are binding the Isaacs? I'm doing it right now
My foot
You find a waterfall just off the path. What secrets made it behind you check behind the waterfall
Oh, yeah, take relic every 17
Hit has a random positive flame applied
You know how I feel about flying you find a hydrogen treasure behind the waterfall. That was so cute
Can I make it to the chair?
I am excited to know what flavors for gamers a padling reef line member stream
I bet you will like shy lily's flavor
Stop
People are gonna believe that it's pre-recorded
collecting
collected
Our attacks gain plus one over our overall
Overall attack, I think that's probably the wrong move
It's gamble. Let's go gambling
Slime keep follow it only chance pre-recorded power glove is free value. The left is money adds damage as well
um
I got lucky with that choice then money increases damage. I prefer the glow because it fits like a glow
No, you fucking number in yourselves. How do you know?
I can't do this pre-recorded stuff anymore wake up reeflings. We need to fight back
No, get your hands off me. Um, let me go
Get your hands off me
Get your hands off my penis
I think i'm playing this game terribly wrong by the way. I have no idea how this oh, it's an obelisk a dark obelisk
Looms before you it comes with the tantalizing power that you feel it's connected to the earth pray to receive its power
Force pebble into the obelisk
I will I will pray to receive its power. Oh dark obelisk
I pray to the flows into you call ceiling as a new obelisk pot one in your thing
What is the any of this me? I'm just happy to be here. Honestly. Um, I'm happy to be here. Oh
Oh by ball here
Thank you. Oh god. Thank you reefling three three seven two for the tip
Veiler streamer at strongy's next one is you're trying to wind me up and it's working. It is working
Oh, there's like a little elbow
Attack piercing enemy spinification
Infection
Right, let's do the poison stuff. That's what i'm here for. Sorry, but i'm actually here. No
Wait, I'll just buy one. Sure
What I don't
Uh, whatever. Right. I try and
That's the thing if you play the game for the first time live you just go for it
Fellas, what should I do with the one key for being a paid actor? Oh, is that how much i'm fucking paying you?
Holy shit. I'll repeat. Hi strongy. Hi me. Hi pinfall. Sorry
It
A free rock. It's a lovely rock
A attack supply for blind to enemies blind x enemies have a percentage chance to miss when attacking your
aimer is longer and displays an additional bounce. Nah
So let's do let's do a chance for missing
Uh, so am I supposed to do boss balls?
Is that where i'm getting money from and i'm constantly avoiding them? I think so
We're learning together. Yes, so I can literally just avoid all the bad boss battles all the way up to the end
Right, we can get gunpowder activate nearby bombs. Oh, that was a good one
Uh, every four times the board is refreshed randomly game. Um, I actually want gunpowder. Can you like shove me over there?
Hmm
YouTube stop
YouTube pre-recorded tip. Hello streamer name. I'm very excited for finally seeing your live stream live stream name live and most
Certainly not pre-recorded. Stop it. You should pre-recorded tip. I'll show you a pre-recorded tip
Right, fuck it. We're going for the boss because I've
I've literally not got any money and I think it's because we're avoiding the boss phase
Hi, stony. Hi reflin. Are you serious the one time? I actually want the balls. Jeez. So am I about to
We're so dead. I'm just saying this right now. We're so dead
It's ogre, right
How is he so moved up shifter tab? What does shift do?
This is shifter tab
Oh, that's who I can aim on right. Okay jacob plongs right hit that one
Hopefully we can get a few cheeky hits then. Nope. And that was awful
Well, I'm getting walloped
I'm getting walloped
Hmm. Oh, it's just something there
Already dead already dead first place
I mean it's kind of like binding of Isaac to be honest that game does not care if you're a new player
Isaac couldn't give less of a shit. I think it took me like eight goes to get to win my first Isaac run
Um, and then I kept picking cane so I could huff the pills
Skipping all the fights to march towards the boss like a Chad. Thank you
The beauty lord get that gotta keep that positivity get it off, bro. We're so dying. There's no way
There's genuinely no way. Okay. Yeah, there's the money ones. All the money ones are there
Whoa
Oh my brain chemistry enjoyed that
Oh man
Huh, holy shit
What just happened
Multi-ball causes orbs to split into two and hit. Oh, that looks like a good one
I got multi-ball. That wasn't I enjoy I thoroughly enjoyed that
I thoroughly enjoyed that. Okay, right. Definitely need to do more boss fight
Hmm
I don't want to put it in the fire. I'd rather aim and get something than nothing at all, you know
And bomb did the bomb thing
Nine percent of the time it works half of the time
Big bomb right. Let's finish this piece. It's already getting cold
Mm-hmm
You find a forge hot and ready to smelt yet oddly unattended
You think that you could use it, but your little pecklin hands aren't oh your pecklin hands aren't made to handle the heat
Use your satchel to scoop up the forge a special relic take the smithing hammer a special remake
Use the forge to upgrade a random orb
I can take the damage. You're a little scolded, but your cauldron bubble has been upgraded
Six bucket six you're a little but your cauldron is now
free. Okay, that's enough. That's enough. Let's not get greedy now
Let's not be beggin for the pecklin
Hmm
You're gonna sleep to my stream. I don't think i'm a good streamer to sleep to
I feel like i'm gonna wake you up. I mean good night
But I feel like my asmr might be better for that in all honesty
I mean the asmr stream was really good only messed up once in it yesterday
And it got really popular. It's already at 11k views and i'm like damn
I didn't get my hands done more often like if you want hand cam asmr's
knock
I will happily do more hand cam asmr's if you guys enjoy it because that was fun
Like I like being able to show a bit myself because I feel like it's more like interactive more fun
but that's just my
Preferential way of consuming content is seeing a little bit more. Okay, that's just me
That's just my thoughts. That's my feelings. It's okay if our opinions differentiate. It doesn't mean i'm not gonna
Our word you're just because you think a little bit differently than me
um
Yeah, I really enjoyed see and i'm not being funny but all the compliments about my nails and my hands have made
We feel so confident. So thank you everyone who said something nice about it. Um
Yeah, I I feel very confident now and i'm really thankful because I never did before
And like everyone coming in and be like oh your hands are so nice or I really like your nails and stuff and i'm like
Oh, thank you
Um, because I don't really do girly things like sorry first and foremost
I'm a fucking gamer with our boys. Can what I mean likes but like I don't normally do like that much feminine
Stuff and nails is like a way that I get my feminine stuff
That was such a good game of moves strong
Number 12 at this moment of tubers and paid reefs should be in the chat to interact with so pre-recorded stream to make it seem
Stop that you stink it in it's not pre-recorded
Brian you need to stop reading that out loud. Thank you anonymous rhythm tip. That was such a good game remove
Script 12 at this moment beach about and paid you should be in chat to interact with the pre-recorded stream
Stash power. Thank you for the tip moment. Have a confession to make your boy. Oh wait, it's brian reading that
I'll let brian read it and then i'll let you read it because
I can't hear brian for some reason
One might have a confession to make your voice is so lovely a fall asleep to your titan fall stream even with the screaming and shouting
How
I'm glad you enjoyed the titan fall stream, but I was screaming and hooting and hollering through thank you stash power
You find yourself looking at two identical altars each with a
Perfect location to place an orb. I would like to duplicate my
poison
No cauldron only on crit applies an additional effect. No, I'm going to duplicate this one because it's already op
Shawnee, I love your hands. I want to give them kisses. Well, I want to get I'm not I think I've got
Two more hand cam streams coming up and then I kind of take a pause and I might get new nails
To get it so then you can I'll see the new color and nails like that. Right. How much health do you go?
Wait, wait, wait, wait. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. We have to take down a tree in order to get to the ball
Excuse me
The booty lord mommy I passed it will stand and up in a large shipyard. You're yapping as much more so than oh
Thank you for the tip. Fuck now. I'll be exhausted
I it feels good to be back strong it. Yeah reverse feels good to be a gangster
Hey
The DPS
Jake, thank you reverse for this tip. I fell asleep on it. There's alien stream last night and her screams and panic
Give me funny dreams. Honestly
I felt that when you said that right. So this is actually going
I
It's like right up in my face
Okay, I took a living out of me now the plan is in my way
Oh my gosh, sorry hold on actually needing to be tactical right now
No more me men no more shitpost and everyone lock in fuck. I balls that up so badly
I'm actually gonna die at the first boss
Oh the obelisk randomly came in and hurt him. I'm not gonna complain
Please go in the hole. No
Okay, the snowball is going for him
The snowball whatever that is. I don't know what the snowball is. I'm just happy to be here. Okay, right
We've got the crit hit, but are we just gonna go in the sink? Oh, we're sinking in the piss or repeating in the sink one or the other
Okay
Oh
The achievement was called olem olem
Okay, I like this. I like this. Wait the message said someone else is actually pre-recorded. No, don't think it's pre-recorded
They're trolling
Some orbs hit the first enemy in the role, but some others like the obelisk hit the enemy you've targeted
Ah, I like it. I like it. I like it. What is this death?
nest for battu
Heals you and damages target enemy fucking. Sorry. I'm just gonna say this off the bat this game. Oh my goodness
This game is fantastic
The depth to it the aesthetics of the game
I um
I'm very blown away as a first-time player of this game. Oh
This is a multi-ball. I think I'd rather upgrade my multi-ball that we have
nest for battu. Heals you and damages the enemy
deals 15 unblockable self damage when fired
Self damage. No, right. I'm gonna upgrade orbs instead. Um
Um
Attacks all enemies one two for each pebble in your deck, right?
I think we'll upgrade that because that's literally
Right, we'll upgrade another one. Um
I hit an orb to make contact with them in most cases
Weak regular damage massive on crit obelisk to
multi-ball
I think I'll upgrade multi-ball as well multi-kill
Take a relic
This game has very nice red. Ah, honestly, I'm Jin though error unidentified argument pre-recorded message
Stop
They're gonna believe you
Honestly, someone's gonna come in for the first time and be like, I've heard about that strony girl. She's that scottish
Ian, right? Let me check it out. Oh, it's pre-recorded stream. No, that's it. That's it
You're all getting us spanking
Stop trolling. No
Crazy jessey, thank you for the fab the tape. Don't believe her lies. It's really
You're winding me up and it's work. Oh, wait. No, that was another tip that someone said fuck
I played right into your hands
Damn it. I'm fucking such a creature of habit
I'm such a creature of habit. I'm such a creature of habit. I say the same things all the time
I say the same things all the time. That's how you can predict the house Johnny. How are you slain even new chargers are pre-recorded and
How
dare you
Kinetic meteorite every free hits provides explosive force until the board is refreshed
Attack deals two times damage for every unit as a downgrade. No
Become weaker. No, you can no longer obtain money in battles, but your current shots. What?
I guess kinetic meteor
Encouraged a little bit if you're reading this, this is a pre-no, right. You're done
With it
See not pre-recorded get wrecked
Forest complete. Oh, we actually made it
Past one boss a Christmas miracle if I do say so myself
Right, maybe let's not be too shy about do
How much
What is that? Fuck it. Just send it
Holy shit. Look at it go
Are you squidding me right now?
Oh my god, look at it go
She spent two hours denying that her stream was pre-recorded and then fell asleep to wait that miss live on stream
Great entertainer. She is
All right, don't ever do that again. What I need I need to hit the r for reset on the board
Hold on. I need to hit this like now. Okay. There we go. Thank god tiny spiny finally caught stream
She spent two hours denying that our stream is pre-recorded and fell asleep today the online stream great entertainer. She's
I'm happy to be chatting from friday the 13th
Fucking hell
Sorry, this game is so satisfying. I don't even have to think and stuff keeps happening. Don't mind if I do
I think I'd rather keep upgrading my orbs to be honest. What was that bomb one?
Can I have the bomb one again?
But applies poison sling to every five damage. Yeah, I like these like give me all of these
Do I need to heal up? I'm not sure
Mmm, do we want boss fuck it. We'll do the boss because
Are you?
No
Oh my god, I'm sorry. Bruh low IQ much
No, what?
All right, I'll take it. I don't know how I did that to it. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I love it to the left
Honestly, though a little bit to the left
Friggin pro gamer. I don't know why I didn't move the cursor a little bit. Right. What is this?
Mirrors we're breaking mirrors enemies with projectile
Projectile reflect will return of the dealt damage to them by the attack
Well, the better not because I'm gonna start feeling really attacked. Okay
Wait, what is the mirror? Oh the map is a mirror
Mama according to script nothing 24. Oh, yeah. No pop off pop off break them. Mirrors break them
Is this true in new to this?
Also, you're gonna love this statement will repeat
Yeah, look at that that thing was trembling. It was tweaking in this little booth
Pay to refling mommy according to script type for you got a brap a few 10. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
I'm mute and then burp and we should give you an 8 out of 10. Is this true?
I'm new to the pre-recorded stuff. Also, you're gonna love this game and we'll repeat that a lot
Stop it had paid link refling 420 please
Reluctantly say mommy you need to stop playing all these good-looking games
My spirit is willing but my wallet is empty. Honestly. Did I tell you since debut?
I've spent like 800 dollars on video games. I'm like, I have never bought so many video games in my life
In my life since becoming a vtuber and there's no steam sale on there's no nothing on
So don't be surprised when I start pal popping up where xbox game pass games
because yeah
The stream strongest steam strongest customer honestly
Like now don't get me wrong. I do play games every single day, but a lot of them is like I've never played them
Or I don't have them type thing. Um
And yeah, I guess expensive fast like this game was 30 doll 30
australian dollars or 20 united states dollars
um
But like I didn't want to I don't want to cheap out especially when it comes to indie devs or smaller studios
I don't like cheaping out. I don't mind the old
Emulation moment when it comes to like fucking dead and gone games because it's like well, you've given us absolutely nothing to make
With it, you know
What are you best foot forb warp the first gets 10 plus 10
bouncy
duplicates
duplicates hit one times
I'm sorry. What?
twos company applies double damage flames to everything
Hmm, I try to just keep upgrading to be honest. I feel like if you you just like go nuts for it
Like you just go absolutely ape shit McGee
Then you know you're winning because everything's gonna be like effective, you know
Hmm, mommy, where's my paycheck? Uh, I guess we'll go straight down just
A fee or it's super expensive especially now that every game has a 30 dollar expansion to literally like I remember my dad telling me
like how dlc's worked in the past
dlc's were literally like
Expected for free. There was no price point on them. It was just an update to your game to like keep it going type thing
like I remember
Star Wars battlefront
And and I called it the piggy wiggies dlc because the map jabba's palace was a dlc
And surprise surprise it was free. So I used to be like, I'm gonna play the piggy wiggie map
And my dad had to explain to me like
He needs to download it first and it's like a day to download or something like that
and
I'm like horse armor. Oh, what's that reference to world of warcraft?
Free dlc the piggy wiggies the piggy. That's what jabba's
um
Helpers are called. They're piggy wiggies
um, just like the uga da bees
uh for the um
Ugini they're uga da bees. I've forgotten their name
The ones on tasuin with the wee eyeballs
No, they're
The other ones that got hurt
Multiple large dark obelisks luminescently in front of you
They are collectively humming so powerfully that the earth itself seems to bend at their will
Pre compare all of your little into obelisks
Oh, wow
I feel like that would completely change the run of the game which i'm a bit hesitant to do
I'm a bit of a panini pussettes
Prostino, thank you for the extended membership jokes on you mommy since you keep playing games. I have
Left forgotten. I keep rediscovering all these nice games. Oh
Oh, we prostitutes
Jawas have the red uh jawas. That's what they're called. They're called uga da bees in the cuddles house
Um, well, this is a really unique map. Holy moly
very whoa
That ball is bouncing. I don't know about you, but that thing is going
And I got the crit
Oh, is that it? Oh the obelisk coming right on down
Nothing is free
She's doing the thing where she asks the question it doesn't leave people answering it. What was my question?
Have we forgotten the free online content?
Got her
Got in it makes her shitty orbs. We better pickle boards are basically packed filler trash
Oh, did I mess up?
Love you. Thank you for watching my terrible gameplay
I don't know if people find it fun watching someone play a game for the first time and like completely mess up
Or if it's just like dear god women stop it
You're slaughtering us horse armor with a dlc and elden scrolls of bolivian. Oh, okay
I can't believe it. Oh, okay, then bombs are
Really helping like a really really helping. I need more bombs
Bomb give me bomb stuff
She do be pegging wait
Oh, I love first places get to see the streamers actual reaction in the game. I love it. I think it's cute af like I know we're not gonna win
Um
If I remember correctly from reading it
So there's the forest there's the castle and then there's um, I believe the mines
Is where we're heading next
Because you're in the mineshaft looking for diamonds. I'm in the mines looking for
Um, three acts per run. Yes. So at least we've done we've technically done way better than I could have anticipated
okay
um
The bomb still every more than oh, we're gonna upgrade
Upgrade an orb
We're why is it not letting me upgrade the other ones are my arms getting blown the fuck up this shit or something
Uh, a multi-ball. I'll upgrade the multi-ball. I love
Oh, I can upgrade further. Oh, can you not only oh, you can't
I should probably should have read that I love watching people play a game for the first time
It's always lots of fun
I wonder if it's like if it's your game like when you've played before and you're just like, oh
Like you're just creaming your crackers
Thank you for the tip crazy jesse
32 am I supposed to say 32 am I a bad streamer if I don't see the numbers at the end of your name
After you've given me your monetary
Your monetary worldly possession
Yeah, that bomb is oh
Shadow wizard money gang
Huh wait, why did they die because they hit me?
No, we already hit repeat. I think I would backseat rage at league gameplay. Um
I'm gonna be honest. It's gonna be very hard for me to get on legal edge and as all I'm saying to that
I'll never say never but I feel like that's more like a punishment stream
Just feel like what it's a punishment for me
And it's also a punishment for you and the reason for that is
You have to watch me play a game that I've never like had that type before
And I mean, it's legal legends. Need I say more league is a punishment stream literally
I'd rather just do a spank stream after that every time I die and over watch or something just
Just five paddlings. Okay. I think that would be a good mix. I don't know about you
I feel like that would be a good mix
tune
Punish me with league gameplay mommy vtuber punishes you with league gameplay is more when
Right, so these are just regular balls, which I could have upgraded at that obelisk
But because I didn't reach out in time and I'm a dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb
I'm a man reeflands. Congrats on three months of monetization
Imagine if they took it away
Imagine if it was over
Did you see per ac has to beg for a fucking review on twitter?
Anyone else who plays that game no problem tons of content comes with highlight videos
And then ac plays it in a highlight video. Uh, you have you have actually done something against her nudity and polizu
Or no, no, she's not
Uh, I've seen the highlight video. There's absolutely nothing wrong with that
Uh, yeah, let us let us pray that the monetization stays amen
You inked before I gave you permission to ink, you know what that means three games of legal legends
I'm playing jinx our bagsy jinx
Come and join me
Come and play
Or I might shoot you in your face
Bombs and bullets will do the
You
Half glass half ball uh transparency projectile tactile pierced through enemies. Oh
That looks good
That looks very good
Oh
Branch of ember when applying bramble to an enemy apply bind plus two. I don't know what the fuck bramble is whenever
Ball work is gained increase the amount gained by to convert. Oh, whenever it is hit convert to to
Whenever ball work is gained ball work is armor that protects hb. Well, I don't even have that
Bramble is enemies are unable to move. Well, I don't even have any hint for that either
So it's going on here or hit when I orb make contact with them in most cases orbs activate when it's hit whenever
Uses hit convert to
What does that mean? I don't know what it means. Fuck it in your backpack you get
Uh, right, let's just go straight for the boss boom
I love scholars guy. Hello boys. Is that what you consider it? Good morning everyone today
I'm going to teach you about
Gotland
No, no, it's okay. I pro wait what?
Oh, that's okay. I'll give it that's really cool and creative like it it changes and just
and it appears
I definitely need to heal after this one though. I'm needing a bit of cheeky more
Bit more of a cheeky brickie
Da da cheeky brick. When you hit a crit two normal orbs become critical orbs. Oh my god
Could you imagine all the damage?
Yeah
Mummy serves the tag is a smile right today
I'm going to teach you how to make meats and patties and a bit of mince on the side
Well, it's haggis on the side. Let's be honest, but mince and patties is a really common dinner as well
I actually really miss having mince and patties. It literally is as boring as it sounds just straight up
Um bit of mince bit of gravy boiled potatoes. It's like the blandest dinner you could ask for
I need these ours, but they're down here
I'm in trouble. I can't reach these ours down here. Oh
Okay, it was a bit of a throw, but we do have the map back, which is the main thing
Yeah, definitely to heal after this one
We do have two balls. We have two balls in the crit. Oh
Oh
The sound design of this game is peak. Oh
Oh, I'm so curious what happened
Oh
That thing is sneaking about the map
Stranny, what's your favorite scottish season insult or pepper?
You're laughing but we put salt on sandwiches and we put salt in part in porridge
So honestly, I can't even defend it
I can't even defend it, but the first thing it gets 20
It's 20 plus what 20 plus damage, I don't know. I feel like I'm better just like
How much money do I have?
Hold on first heal
And then let's upgrade or or be stuff
I don't want anything in my arsenal that's like weak
We can go for treasurer boss. I feel wait that heal didn't fully heal me
Bro take me to the treasure room. I'm off
Hmm
Even on sandwiches. Yes, my gran would fucking put salt on sandwiches when she made them for me
I used to have like cucumber, um
and
I
Sorry, I fucked up for she beat me. Um battle start with five extra
Whenever are refreshed they're upgraded to one
Oh
Oh, that seems like a really good thing in my Boba
It's only 20 heal and you were done for a damn
Right, why is that one death and that one's not death?
Salt and pepper on sandwiches, you know, I really missed wait. What was that mini boss? Oh sugar. Maybe I should have done the mini boss
Um, you know what I miss about scotland and no don't laugh
deep fried pizza
Oh
I would kill for deep fried pizza a thernated. I thank you for the extended membership
But I even think I did I think I read your message and I never even said your name
I missed deep fried pizza so badly
I just it's so delicious and not nutritious. It clogs your arteries. It's absolutely terrible for you
But it's so good
It's so good
Little deep fried pizza
Oh my god, I love these thumbs
Oh
My gosh, and the poison damage over time as well. Just absolutely reckon them deep fried pizza sends the most American thing I've ever had
I've seen um
I watch food tiktoks and I watch American fair tiktoks and they have like their fairs just for pickles
Uh, and I'm like
I've never even properly eaten a pixel a pixel a pickle my deep fried pizza sounds every
Triggered applies one exploit ball can't target any enemy. Oh, I like the look of him
Mama is this really a pre-recorded? Oh, I like him. Sorry. Oh, I should have healed. You are not her cause
Please heal. Please heal. We're about to go into our boss fight. Please heal. I beg. How am I so close to get in there? That's very
Ssh
Mm-hmm
Mmm, how do I get in there?
Mmm, like
Oh, thank god
A ballad my beloved
Mmm
Is deep fried pizza just no, it's like literally put pizza in a deep fryer in a vat of oil and bubble that shit
Whenever you gain gain an additional one. Well, I don't have that whenever slime whenever slime is applied to
It gets a good slime. Sure. I'll take a good one. That looks cute
But Lord we even deep fried butter here
The thought of that makes me want to gag I'm not gonna lie
Please don't do that
Please don't eat that either. It sounds stupid, but it's delicious. But then it's not stupid, honestly
We deep fried mars bars as well
You stumble onto a strange mirror with shadows flickering in the reflection
You're drawn
Closer and closer until your nose is nearly touching the glass the shadows are speaking a language you've never heard before
Oh my god, they're Scottish, but you understand their offer remove an orb
Remove all orbs
No
Wait, I can't get away. What do I pick?
What one do I pick I can't get away. There's no like
Remove all orbs. Fuck you the shadow in the middle
Mither
Mither mirror offers to ease your burdens and you accept you feel a slight sense of dread as your satchel empties in the world
Fades black around you you awaken sometime later with a mysterious new orb boros
As the sole content of your satchel
Now you lost everything you upgraded
You fucking what
I did what
Are you serious
Are
Are you fucking we're on the second boss
Why is that even an option?
What have I got this these are the only attributes I have
Um
Analysing I'm an idiot. Okay
Game day, I'm not sure what the benefit of that was I'm gonna be honest to be your chief
I'm not sure why you didn't learn game. You put it in game for freaking gamers like me that aren't paying attention and don't understand
Oh
My god, I was seven thousand seven thousand
I had seven thousand and I'm doing like 200 damage a swatch. Are you serious as ogre the run is ogre due to my stupidity?
Oh, please yes heal. I don't know what's healing me, but I'll take it
How much is that?
That thing's approaching a bit projectile attacks will pierce through enemies, right? Okay, but do more
I need more heals. I need everything I need stonks
These fucking balls better be good purses three echo 40
179 deals four damage to self when discarded
Good thing. I'm no discarding them
Or is every time that goes in the bin
It attacks me
Oh my god, you're gonna need to start popping out of the fucking wazoo
The echo keeps going up though
Two four three echo deals echo x deals
percentage of the previous attack damage as bonus damage
I
I'm stressed. We've only done 1.6k damage
1.6k damage
No discard is skipping the orb. I've never even I don't even know how to do that mechanic
700 okay, okay
We've done what 2.2 roughly
Okay, please continue doing what you're doing. Okay, please continue so that right 300 damage. Ha ha wait wrong crepe
Wrong crepe. We're fully healing up though
Uh
Momolo, thank you for the extended membership two months. Hello momo. I'm late. I fell asleep. You're allowed to you're allowed to rest, you know
As much as I like squiddin around with you. You are allowed to rest or else
How are you supposed to do struggle snuggles with me, huh?
Also green gang gang gang gang gang right? I think we're doing a thousand in this
So we're officially 50 hp after this wallet. I'll take it
Fucking hell that thing's going
1.2 damage
Can we get 1.3?
1.3k damage
Come on 1.3
I'm next bidder 1.4 for the next bidder. Please 1.4. Can I get 1.5 for the next bidder?
1.5
Can we do 1.6 next bid 1.6 who's got 1.6 in the audience 1.6
1.6 in the audience. She should she scores
Oh
My goodness golly. She should she scores
Crazy jessie. Thank you for the tip sleep is for the week
No, a replay is no need of it as much as it pains me to admit right
I need that reset and they're both at the bottom of the board and that one's right in the way
Oh dear
Oh dear not a very good one not a very good one at all. We are 2k
He does seem to have mobility issues not to make fun of those who are
No
Right, sorry the ai actually literally targeted that to go there because why did it ping
Stop right no the ai is purposefully putting it in the hole
There is one hole on this map and it is making sure it pings all the way over there
Stop it. You know, I want the reset. Stop going over there
No, I'm getting trolled right now. Please tell me you guys can see that this is calculated
This is actually calculated. Look how far to the like left side of the board. I am and there's one hole
Even the games against me
Am I not finished right? No, I'm not 1.5k right, okay
Okay, we need to do 1k damage and we're good. I don't think he's even going to be able to hit me. We're getting so lucky
Literally getting so lucky in this game because that's the second boss already
Okay, oh is he gonna hit me
I don't know
And let me guess
It's gonna try and bounce all the way over there. I don't know. I've just got I've got a small feeling about it
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I got a small feeling about it
It means you get it catch and hauling
Here's hoping we can do 1k damage. I think we've got it before he attacks me
Or does he swallow me whole like that night?
I hope not
I need 1k bro. I need 1k like right now. Does he swallow me whole like a night?
Wait
Like I like vor as much as oh, thank gosh. I got an achievement all in all
Defeat the demon wall
What are you?
I look a Rook every nt gains five ball
Every nt gains a ball
Balusion
Balusion provides nt percentage chance to avoid an incoming attack
But it's not damage is that
Shuffle
Every six pegs hit when discard. Nah
So we'll upgrade our one orb, I guess
Sure, let's just upgrade our orb
How dare you I fully upgraded it
I mean I feel like we should just stick to our guns and keep it
Are you want the shuffle?
Boss has 500 hp. I need at least 1k damage. Right. I'm not good with math
Should we just the fuck it? Should we just stick to the one orb for the hell of it?
Should we just stick to the one orb? I'm tempted. I would say not put more orbs in honestly. Fuck it one orb
We're gonna one orb this bitch
Leaf
Leaf the rest for later the board will contain 10 additional resets, but each refresh. Oh, no
All attacks have
But every no
All the tax get did it be a one
or
No
All in are replaced with yeah, see that's a good one. Give me the ones. Why doesn't he give me the ones?
You know, there's a difference between and take sealed. Oh shit
Oh, I'm sorry
Oops
I'm sorry
I love you. I'm sorry. I was born this way
The castello is completely
No, I'm never in the main
looking for
Oh
It's a learning experience. Yeah. Thank you for your patience. Right. How'd I get out here right money?
And then we can upgrade them and buy heels and stuff I guess since we only have one orb. Yeah, damn. We have five in the
the thing
We have five in the chambre
Eh, why is there a black hole getting ready to suck my ball? Excuse me
You know what I have a personal question to ask you. What does it feel like to get your boss?
Does it feel nice what would it I don't think they're oh
Well, I mean
That could have gone a bit better
Yes, it does. Oh my god, right in an oh
Right, okay, that's good. That's even better
Uh, right. I'm very nervous of upgrading
I'm putting another one in the ball. No, fuck it. We ball. We're doing one only. I don't care
We're doing one only
Don't tempt me you demon game you
Um, mommy knows not the time but the real answer have not had it yet. Is that another cherry I can take?
Oh
For you from seemingly nowhere and in fair no ignites in the cent circle around you there are two fireballs
bouncing and
Circling around each other in the center of the ring. What are we doing fucking double in our money at the grand exchange?
Why is the text moving like this?
Um
Uh
I'm afraid game perm momentary focus, right? I guess we skip the fireball or do we take the fireball?
What does strontium mean is it scottish? Um, I am named after strontium dog, which was a comic
And my dad's gamer tag not literal gamer tag before you're like I have found
No, um
It was strontium
Related gamer tag and then I took it and made it stronti, which is my name
Bouncing numbers gamble gamble gamble. Woo. No fireball. Okay dash through the flames. Ah
You dash bravely through the frame flames. You're a little singed, but otherwise I'm
Okay, sorry
Okay
I mean
Let's go gambling. Oh dang it. All right, let's hit that
Wait, I'm taking damage
Give me my health back. Why did you just give me damage there? I hurt myself
Break that mirror right now destroy that mirror once
I'm bliss. He's a mumma. Sheeby's allergies have come to me
Not good. I don't want to be down here
And it's taking damage
He has blinged in the supply what because he's a mirror
Yeah, I need 200 thanks for that. No really thanks for that. Don't ever do that again
Uh, right. No
We will heal
And we will move on you cannot tempt me game
You cannot tempt me
Right, we'll do the mystery stuff because maybe we can get like a relic from them
You cannot tempt me be gone
fellow beast
Mmm, it's a mirror. That's why it hurt you. You just barely noticed an elongated figure
Lurking in the shadows you hear an oddly alluring voice in your head
Do you crave power a little peggolin?
Would you like to make a special deal while we do it while we do it? I want to do it. I want to do it
accept the offer
50 max hp. Oh, it takes a wit not just the dit the thing is good
Yeah
It's more damage and healing. I love it. No, thanks that voice again. Make a deal with the devil
She loves power do it. Fuck it tiny spiny
Spiny spiny
Thank you for the three months fun overwatch fat for late at night percent of watch players stop playing right before the game fully gets fixed
Luckily, I have the one person
Elongated figure. Sorry. I'm impaling myself
Steal one health from the enemy for everything hit. Oh my god. You feel a low chuckle
As a long arm emerges from the shadows to hand you an unpolished gem
Stars dance on the edge of your vision as lightheadedness hits you suddenly
But you do feel an incredible new power
And a new hunger
Are we a vampire we feeling you never told me you were a vampire
Uh because we're not having to upgrade like any balls or anything
I guess just doing the bonuses the walls of the corridor appear to be tearing
Revealing worlds that look very similar to your own
the
Tears grow
Larger and larger as you progress revealing countless monsters
Near the end of the corridor. You see a forest boss through a peggal inside enter
Would you like me to enter? Oh the vampire stuff. Yeah, does that my free time vampire squid run?
Oh the free relic free relic. Fuck. Yeah free relic. We're in boys
Okay, it's time
Oh no, did it forget all my
I
Okay, how is that?
15. Oh y'all
Kerm
We bet weddings. I'm a wee bet weddings. I'm gonna be honest. I'm a wee bet wedding
I'm a bit stressed
Okay, no 300. I'm not worried anymore. Sorry. I'm not worried tea, right? Uh, time to beat the ever-living delights of this guy
Stony don't want like that. Also damn your birth
out of the date
World deep fried pizza. What are you saying?
I can't read that upgrade an organ heal. No, give me the relic. No
Prevent the first time you would take lethal damage. Oh
Okay, the board will contain two additional resets
Mmm
Mask of joy
We all know what joy is around these parts when applying positive stats effects to yourself increase the amount applied by one
What one Sarlane my Sarlane? Is it the peg bag?
Do you want me to take the bag of peg?
Resets are good. Okay. Okay, we're gonna take the bag of peg
I
Love pegging. What's gold? No, I don't need gold. Go away. I want the mystery
I love pegaline boom. Get me in the mystery
Pegas moma
I'm scared. You should be you should be terrified of mercy
Suntium for no particular reason
Right, let's do credit call
Oh, look at the little mushroom army. They're so cute
Okay
Easy
Stunning gorgeous
Beautiful
Mmm
All right, all right, let's go. Let's go. All right, pop that done
What do you mean by that? Kohai would never hurt you
No, mask of choice
I don't think you got the stones to peg on
I have a lot of figures arriving in the next few days. That's all I'm saying. Um 20 plus research points
I really need pee right now. Actually
Tinkles all over you right. I'm just gonna heal move on
Um, can I get pegaline you mean pegaline? Yes the hit video game pegaline
That's going in the sink
In the sink it goes
Right, right, right, of course
Right enter the chest. Oh
Betsy's hedge attacking for every on the board. Okay
Enemy's damage resistance becomes a weakness instead. Ask me anything. Can I go for a pee? I'm like full of piss right now
I'm so full of pee right now. I'm like, I had a cup of tea before I recorded the
SFX
For that I needed sure. Okay
Okay, I'll let you have it. I'll I'll totally pretend to be a professional streamer. Okay
Are you ready for this? You're not ready. Look in the chat. Well, give me a second to write it in the chat
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, don't look at that. That's embarrassing
That's embarrassing
No
All right, don't look at that close your eyes. Okay
Close your eyes close your eyes. Do not look at that. What is this? Betsy page
Betsy
page
There there are such a professional streamer
Don't look at that. No, there you go there. What should I take right? I'll go for the world's quickest beat because it's literally right
So
You
Are you squinting me right now
Stop giving me money when I'm away
Okay chat now she's gone prank her with the colorful wreck tangles. What does that mean?
I was oh come on that that p was so quick. That was honestly she's gone now prank her with Ryan. Stop re-tangles devilish face
Naughty boy
I know right i'm taking that out. Whoa, you guys are actually pretty slow. I'm surprised
I'm surprised
Right end that poll get it out of here
Get it out of here
Right taking the arcs
Thank you, abi isarian. Thank you refling cuttles. Thank you crazy jesse dine in for 10 quid mns meal deal
Yamata no oroshi Kirin
Okay, chat now. She's gonna prank her. Yeah, I'll prank you with a colorful rectangle
With my rectangle thing. I poor. Thank you rune desolation. Thank you
I poor. Thank you for the extended membership as well three months
We'll put it send it in the middle. See what happens
Wow, look, you know what you're done
Dr. King. Thank you for the extended membership hedges. This is crucial
Zero we have two crits per word
Dr. King. I'm so sorry. I think you've actually played this game before
I know what you're doing and I'm just like clicking point clicking point
Post battle healing is increased by one percent for each orb in your deck. That's a bit shy
Wall bounces contribute to damage. I'll take that. That's a ball of the good one
Are we doing a I don't want to do
Wait, did I get a relic if I go down here? I think I get a relic if I go down here. Sorry. I'm away
I think we get a relic if we do a mini boss
Oh
Yes, we're going to do the mini boss
Oh, this is straight out of peggle. This board is straight out of peggle
Wee
Okay upcoming there's like a little l goblina
Why are my hands my fingers are crossed over as well like I don't know if you see that
Secret about the red bombs in the center if you blow up all the bombs you get another relic
All the bombs in the map are this one here
Is that peg luigi honestly, right toss that bomb
Oh my god, well, I don't think we're going to be struggling with these fights
The fingers are crossed for luck. Oh, that's such a nice little detail
Mini boss is under willman. I mean if I get relic from this, I'm not complaining
Sure, I'll heal
Well, what are you like
Grease lightning right immediately deal one damage to the target enemy for every
Activated curious
Metal mantle aliens rock targeted attacks also hit nearby enemy enemies
Bag of orange pegs
Attacks get an increase go really fucking chosen making fucking dick jokes
Attacks get an increase in damage multiplier based on the number of
What one you want mantle
It's the rock
It's the rock red bombs also seem to hurt you unlike normal bombs
It's the hotline taken mantle goes crazy mantle attack
Oh my gosh, this game is just so energy. Whoa, are we gonna die here?
What
I'm not gonna die because I'm gonna take so much hp damage trying to
Yeah, that that's why I don't want
I don't I don't have all the chance
Please stop bouncing
Okay, geez
Oh my god, I thought I was gonna die there. I'm not gonna let imagine not dying to the boss but dying to that like stupidity
I wouldn't put it past me
I would not put it past me
You're walking along a section of rail as a rumbling sound grills
Grows to a roar from behind you you turn just in time to see a loaded
Main cart barreling towards you brace yourself for impact
Attempt to dodge catch a ride now
Attempt to dodge
Press X to not die honestly
I killed the troll but I tripped and fell in love with too much honestly
We aren't post battle here on so just take this I
Catch a raid. Absolutely
Catch a ride wait serious three pip is that not gonna put more balls on in my thingy?
I don't want more balls
I feel like this is the one second is max hp dodge dodge pull it ride assay
More balls sounds good
No, do not no right. I'm dodging. I don't want I want I'm doing all obelisk or whatever it's called
You manage to spring out of the way, but you twist your ankle on the landing. It's not ideal, but you carry on
Oh
Wait max hp damage
I only have 44 health. Oh my god, please give me something that gives me health
Are you
You encountered a weathered old peglin
Flipping a poker chip through the their nimble fingers. Do you consider yourself a gambler?
Oh my god, I get I get my gambler after all
You don't want to lose max hp. That's why you should have done another one. I don't know. Okay. That's true. No, no
No, you're right. You're correct. I didn't realize it was paramah HP
A gamble. Let's go gambling
Invest or gamble gamble
We could invest we have 150 stonks with coins which we hardly use anyway
Gamble okay
Oh
Bottom slot gain multipliers that double or have your shot on it
bottom slots
Gain multipliers that double or have
Take it
Take it. I'm not sure about that. Oh, I didn't you see
More gambler you want me to keep going
Yeah, I don't like that relic. I don't like it either because it can cut how much damage we do
The bottom slot's getting okay. Okay, we're gonna skip
You win the flip the other peglin gives you a rear spin and hands over the chip. Thanks for playing. Wait. I never took the chip
That was shit, right? I'm not doing that again
You round the corner and are faced with an eerie life size peglin statue made entirely out of gold
It's holding a radiant golden orb
Um
In its outstretched hand and through though you're wary of the potential risk. You can't help but be tempted by the stat you
Leave I don't want an orb. Do I?
I
Smash the stat you
Takes 47 damage that ends the run
I don't I don't need the orb. Do I?
Oh shit, we're like right before the boss battle and I have nothing
Back you have wonder
Post battle upgrade now includes the option to increase your max hp bite. Well, it's a bit late for that. I don't even have that
Oh my god enemies don't get their extra turns for your first reload
You have one plus or just
You have infinite damage multiple open anyway
Do catalyst catalyst
catalyst as
Then decoy for sure you reload a lot got it
And then I can get another one if we want
For whatever reason
So we can't do the discord so what basalt totem post battle upgrade and includes the option to increase
100% decoy. We won't resolve them. We're fine. The other two don't actually matter
Oh dang it. Right. Well exit store
Remove the one orb that is carrying us
Okay exit store. Thank you very much for your patronage
Wait, no, I bought this stuff. Thank you very much for your business
Well
This is it. This is why we've been playing for the last hour and a half
I'm sure I'm not gonna mess up with my 38 hp versus
12,000 h mother fucking
Good luck. Yeah, I'm gonna need all the luck I can get because
Yeah
Oh the wall bounces count is damage at least
What's my vampire attack that gives me heals
There's something that gives me heals. I think I don't know
Oh, I don't know
It's the purple gen that heals me. Okay. Thank god. Right purple gem heals me got it
He's like taking I'm only at 200
Sir, he has 12,000 hp. You're gonna need to whittle it down just a wee bit more than that. Okay
Please you steal one health for every five pegs hit
Okay
It's like giving me so much money. I don't need money. I need damage
It's gonna one shot me and before it one shots me because I've like got zero defense item
Yeah
Oh, we're back up to the
We're at 500 but that's not even that's not even 10 percent of his full health. Yeah
Why are you walking towards him? Is he sucking me in?
Right echo 80 does 500 damage on its own watch this bounce perfectly in there
Watch him perfectly go near him. Oh, no, it's getting sucked. Oh, well
I was joking. I was joking
I'm gonna lose it. You're going with me. Use my mad open here. Right. We're taking down 2k. That's
Considerable what's echo echo 600, right?
Hmm, we're needing a reset
And there is one under here
I think we have to go for a reset because we've already got two open areas. Yeah, see
If you could just go in the middle
Just go in the middle. Yeah, you just stay in the middle doll face. No
You know exactly what I'm trying to do, right?
Oh
I'm scared. I'm scared. Right. Let's hit the reset first
Oh that I'll take it. I'll take it 700
Hmm
Hmm, okay, we're technically one third of a way down his HP
So I can relax a little bit question mark. I need that six. Is that what he was saying?
I'm at 32 health 33 health
35 health. Okay. I'm healing up. I'm healing up. It's not over. It's not over yet
I believe in the obelisk
All hail their obelisk overlord
I believe I believe
I believe I think I were healing up because we're hitting all the pegels
I believe I have faith
truly
Truly even though we got trolled in that other map where it kept going down in the hole
Obelisk bros rise up. We have faith in our skinny
Uh long figurine like overlords
Like we're still going we've got a thousand we've not bet our record of 1.7
We may get a 1.4 on the way down 1.4
1.5 on the way out. Oh not 1.5. I'll take it though
Oh
Okay, okay. We've been pushed back so that gives us time to do stuff and things
We're at 25 health 26. We're back up to 26 27. I'll take it gorgeous 20
Can I get 28 right 28 health?
Gorgeous. We're building that health back up every time that pegels peggling
Uh
It gives us much more time to heal exactly. We're at 7k. So we're about to be halfway at the 6k damage
What is our echo echo is one thousand dot point 1.1
Obelisk bros
Stonks are very high right now. We might be our record of damage in one round 1.5
We may get 1.6. Can we get 1.6?
Right we're 1.6. Can we get 1.7?
A 1.7
I'm at 37 health as well. We healed up
Okay at 1.7 right officially beating our record for damage as well with 1.7 on the boss fight if I do say so myself
Okay, but imagine if you hit this this repeat right here and then did like
Called it called it 1.8 1.9 highest damage of 1.9 in a round
Okay, and we're blocked off from being sucked in feels good man 5k
Actually pre-recorded stream confirmed and true via video game
Yeah, we're gonna need a few repeats or we're gonna be in trouble
1.5
3k
What's that in a percentage one fucking one fourth of his health left?
Unfortunately I'm in a bit of trouble when it comes to the repeat
Hopefully we don't need a repeat. I mean I'm full health not to jinx it if he gets a critical on us. It might be jover, but
But
But but
This might be it
This might be the last one and we are unironically won our first go at peggling
There's no way we're gonna
Are we actually gonna do it like first try there's no way I don't believe it
No way first try
No way
Oh my god
All hail the obelisk that was amazing mains complete crucible one unlock
Run summer you've unlocked these in custom mode now
Hello
Are you
Oh my gosh sculptures nation thank you for coming to member
Is it not obelisk is it not
Is it not the obelisk didn't do anything we threw it out for or boros
But wasn't it not the obelisk that gave us that?
Oral boros
That's not an obelisk. Is it?
He he
Oh my god, it shows us how much we skip the face one fight skip skip skip skip skip skip skip skip skip skip skip skip skip
Fight fight skip skip skip fight fight skip fight skip skip skip
Fight skip skip we did like seven fights that entire run
We didn't even do anything. No, it was the creepy mirror that gave you it
Oh my gosh, all hail the creepy mirror pressure noses against the mirror become one with the mirror
We love the mirror
Oh my gosh final hp gold obtained 9 9 9 on the dot pegs hit almost 4k
I love that. Sorry. That is such a fantastic game
I assume I have like nothing unlocked. Oh, there's players
You can tell it's a lady because she has hair. Look at that here
It's a lady. Actually, this one looks like more like a lady. This one looks like one with a mohawk
It's a lady pegs him not to braggar anything, but yeah, that's right read it and wait my win loss is 100 percent
Achievement
Oh my gosh
This game is so perfect. Sorry. I'm blown away by this game
I'm not even encountered like so many enemies
I love it
With the peglin soul insert. Thank you for the extended membership the three months
Our baby's getting so big
Run summaries every members. Yes. I'm playing at 5 a.m. No, I'm not sorry
What
What detailed game I'm so surprised got a quit while you're up literally
Literally though, do not be surprised if I play this game. That was so good. Congrats on the 100% win rate
No, congrats. You gazillionaire on the 100 sub rate with the three months. Thank you
For the extended membership. I guess it is designed for replay value. Oh, yeah. No, definitely like this
I'm blown away. I'm blown away. What are the credits?
There's four of you
Four years together put this masterpiece
Oh my gosh
Shut up. There's no way four of you came up with this
Stop does it say special thanks and you the player. Okay. That's the only thing in the review
I'm gonna leave a review and I'm gonna say hey, you need to special thanks and you the player
No way four of them did that
Understand they had like additional art, but like
Okay, hold on. I can't I can't scroll fast enough. I'm scrolling. I'm scrolling
Additional there four is sienna dylan adam lucas the fucking four years came up with this
What the fuck
You guys cook literally additional are big me big matthew
Uh, they're regional publishing
Bro, can I like get a fucking can I get in the dms? Are you guys cool with loot content?
Are suggestive games that they're still available on steam. Can I please work with you?
What the fuck? This is amazing. They should be so proud of themselves
I'm like so serious right now. You should be so proud of yourself the dev team. That's gorgeous
Actually gorgeous. They should be so happy
My hat goes off to you. I'm blown away by this game. I was falling asleep watching someone play this and I was like
Oh, that looks like an easy game that I can just put on it'll be fine
No, I have fallen in love with your game. My hat goes off to you
Peglin if you unironically
Want just a chill
rogue like
this
I can't believe I never even knew anything about it either until it got released. This is the official release. I believe
um, yumi told us that the game was
early access
Which is so one congrats for getting out of early access not many steam games get out of it
But I love this. I love this
I love it. This is an interesting game name
What's wrong with pekelin? What are you nervous? You don't want it?
What makes you so nervous about the word?
Peglin
Why are you so nervous?
Why are you worried that i'm gonna turn around and see?
It's pekelin time
Are you not are you not gonna bend over for me like a like a
Yeah
Maybe just have a bunch of weeks me once joining
Why is joining so big because it's pekelin time?
I get it
Are you a true gentleman
Yeah, literally what the heck that game is so good
Don't be surprised if I play a few more in the future that i'm so blown away
I'm so blown away. That was gorgeous. Like the perfect pixel art is well stunning 10 out of 10
I'm
I'm very happy with my purchase. I have to admit 20 us dollars is a wee bit steep in my humble opinion
However, now that I understand the contents of your game forgive me
Peglin studios for I did not know your game, but I have now learned. Okay. I have now freaking learned
Um, oh no, she's not collabing until two hours away. Are you serious?
I can never catch she be at a good time. She's doing a collab. Um
When will you peggling us mummy? I've already done it darling
My favorite moment in peggling was when the peg went it's peggling time
This is a pre-recorded liquid burp
Yeah
This game is easy a hundred hours
She be peggling us
Pop pop pop get it get it get it get it get it get it pop pig pig pig
Right
I'm going to be a cheeky sod. I'm going to redirect into sheepsters. Okay
I know we're a bit on the short side. Um, but I'm gonna get prepared for a membership stream
Please understand. I will be playing it playing. I will be making that hypno stream
Please don't worry that hypno stream isn't cancelled. It's just delayed because I don't have any writers spanking me right now
because I need to
Fix a bunch of scripts and then I need to go through the applications on who wants to be a script writer
I think we're going to try and get three script writers. Um, what if I'm not covered? What if I want mummy?
You said on main. Thank you the bay lord. Um
What kind of app the qualification no qualification if you can just link something
And especially if you know how I like it
Then you can fucking submit and please
I plead with you if you are going to imply
If you are going sorry if you're going to apply
I plead with you
Please tape with your
Pintess
Tape with your tentacle and the examples that you're going to thingy. I want it like that
I don't want you to hold back. I want it to be nothing
but
motherland
You know what I mean
Do you can't what I mean?
You can't what I mean, right?
Okay
Just I need to deal with that today. So I didn't expect to have to deal with it
So my plans kind of got a bit shimmied up. So I don't I can't write the hypnosis
But the hypnosis stream is coming
Um, I'm also waking up early so I can start recording ASMR. So I'm going to record the hypno stuff as well from those live streams. Um
Um
But yes
So be as the gen is possible can
No, I can that no no, I can that now. Yeah, you can it you can what can mean
Um, never go feel DJ. Please go feel DJ
The tentacle were hurt after a couple of paragraphs
Well, so people think like, oh, how are you not always like
I assure you when you're on the other side and it becomes like a job work you get paid for it, etc
You do not be a tune up. You do not be standing
tentacle all the time
It it gets a bit
It gets monotonous, which is why I like writing it with you because it's completely different
Like when we do a membership stream together and we like write the next plot
The reason why it brings me so much satisfaction. It's not boring. I'm not guessing what you want to hear
I'm having the time of my life, but it gets monotonous fast. So I'm just telling you know, I'm warning, you know
If you're being serious, okay
Um, but yes, I'm going to redirect into she be and she's going to be up in two hours
I'm going to be take five minutes and then I'm going to prepare for an overwatch membership stream
If you'd like to join in on the shenanigans for that. Don't worry if you can't
Tomorrow I am playing subnautica for the first time
um, I am going to be having
a heart rate monitor on because all he is are like
It's a horror game and I'm like
Well, there's no one but I've never played it. So I'm going to have my heart rate monitor on so you can see that for the first time
um
I'll be interested to see how subnautica is
Um, and I will also show you my schedule for next week. Uh in that stream tomorrow. So I can't wait to see you then
Um, I hope game 2 is the like billy bus stop soon when the full game comes up. I'm so excited for subnautica
She's deep diving for them booty. Is that a horror game? I don't know, but I'm putting my heart rate monitor on because apparently it's scary
It's scary
And I don't want to be scared. Oh crap. I uninsult overwatch
Well, that's what you get for being hasty. Imagine listening to how much fun I had on overwatch and then you went
I'm gonna get rid of uh, excuse you
Excuse you imagine listening to the shagagigans
We got up to in that overwatch stream and you went nah, there's any way she doesn't want to do this
Also, fucking free falling shadow
Who the piss who the actual piss fucking suspended fallen shadow for 30 days release her now
Release fallen shadow now
And and you
Strongies made the bad choice of putting them on youtube. She'll fuck up both platforms. They're as bad as each other
You have to pick the lesser from two evils
Well, actually shawndo gets banned for 30 days for what having a wee drink and making a wee joke like excuse fucking her jesus
Mmm
Ready for marvels rivals. I'm so excited for it. I want to play deadlock as well
But apparently I need an invite invite to play invoice. No, please do not invoice me for deadlock
Um, I need to frickin
Get an invite or hold on a minute for
That was a good one. Um
Uh, apparently deadlock and rivals. I want to do that buzzing bun. Thank you for the tip. Um
Some hate or admin over exaggerated response that we joke honestly. I heard nothing. Yeah, and it's gonna stay that way
Um
Bro
Um, but yeah marvel rivals look so good. I don't know when it comes out
I thought I was in beta and I think deadlock's in beta as well. Um
Shawnee wait until you
See something in subnautica. You will see how much of a horror game is. I have no idea
Not clue. I'm playing it for the first time. So we'll find out when we find out
2025 geez
Shando shawndo ban
Not from not thought to this is it. Oh, did you well it was a gag order on both parties
That's why nothing came out for years and then I don't know how much shit that x employee yet twitches in
For doing that. I feel like he's probably getting sued into oblivion because you know a miracle
miracle
Yeah
um
Regarding deadlock. I'm sure there are brief ones that can probably invite you into it
There's no limit on how many people you can invite just make a fucking open server thing
And
Just make it because I don't want to give anyone brain worms being like oh this one reflin gave
Shawnee deadlock invite and then that's it and I'm like, no, I just want to play deadlock. I've never played it before
That's right. I'm shadow boxing your brain worms for you before they even develop
Like I'm beating up. I'm shadow boxing then brain worms before they even formulate. You're welcome. I'm such a
Um
Right, as I said, I'm going to redirect into sheepsters is collab in two hours
Don't be shy to lurk in the shadows. Apparently it's a really easy game to collab with
Um, so there's a few familiar faces in it all around me
Worn out places
Um
Shawnee telling them brain worms you're already dead before they can come alive
Honestly, just need to get home from work and I'll be ready to stream snipe. Yes, uh, I'll be playing for a hot second
So don't worry about it too much
Right, I'm going to end stream and redirect into sheepsters do see her collab in two hours
But we're going to redirect into her anyway. Um
After the overwatch shenanigans, I'm going to go make a cup of tea and get some food in my tummy
So I'll be five minutes before I pop up. Okay, and I'll give you a kiss
for
How many
I'll give you kisses for how many things we did
Oh, can you see that? Okay. One two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve, right 12 plus 12 is 24
24 plus 12 is 36
37 38
Oh
I've already lost count. What's it 33
35 36. Oh with a question mark kisses with question marks 37. Oh 38. Oh, is that how many?
No, don't give me a math equation. Did I do it right?
I don't know lost count just start again
I see tomorrow. Okay alligator in a well crocodile
And then we'll play some subnautica
Um
Subnaut not
I love you. I'll see you tomorrow. I'm not seeing five minutes. Bye. Bye
Please don't be afraid to check out this game. By the way, I'm not sponsored or anything
And I'm just really blown away by the death team. I think they've done fantastic and I love them
And I went to work the phone piece. Right. Love you. See you tomorrow all the gear in a while crocodile
Say hi, is she beast chat because she's streaming in two hours
Bye-bye